greetings from podcastville the joint is
brought to you by
draftkings i don't know if you're living
behind a [__] rock or whatever the
[__]
but the biggest college basketball
tournament of the year is heating up
this sunday the brackets come out and
the clock is ticking as the seeds get
ready
for the tip off get off the [__]
bench and get into this tournament
action
bet four dollars on the underdog if they
win
you're up to 256 dollars that's
[__] insanity and it takes four bucks
to get a shot at winning
256 dollars the bank is open [__]
if anybody knows about being an underdog
it's your uncle joey but look at me now
there's no better way to put your
college basketball knowledge to the test
than to put your money where your mouth
is with draftkings sportsbook
do me a favor let's cut this [__]
download the top rated sportsbook app
draftkings sportsbook app now use promo
code joey
when you sign up you're gonna turn four
dollars into 256 dollars
if the underdog of your choosing pulls
off the upset where have you [__]
who takes care of you like draftkings
nobody that [__]
that's code joey to turn four dollars
into 256 dollars for a limited time only
you got to start this weekend with this
listen the brackets get really sad late
sunday i don't [__] know
but i do know this is the way to go
draftkings right now
download the [__] app the top rated
draftking sports book app today right
now and for a limited time
right now we're going to take care of
you with four dollars
to turn into 256 dollars who's better
than [__] you
nobody go to draftkings right now and
download the app and use promo code joey
here's the part the lawyers make me say
you got to be 21 or older go [__] get
your roller skates new jersey
indiana pennsylvania new customers only
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if you have a
gaming problem you got to take care of
it
you got to call 1-800 gambler or in
indiana 1-809
with it but first download the draftking
sportsbook app right now
and tell them uncle joey sent you
there's a tremendous game tonight
with san antonio versus dallas you could
start your [__] action tonight
and you'll be ready for this weekend's
action and if listen
and if college basketball ain't a
[__] thing they got nba
golf hockey they got a full-length
casino
so go to draftkings app right now promo
code joey
the joint is also brought to you by my
favorite lucy
nicotine gum listen it's march [__]
night and you still haven't quit
you've been telling yourself you want to
quit you want to quit when you're
craving a smoke
you just need a little something to
satisfy the habit that's why i love lucy
things may be rough but you don't need
to smoke anymore right now it's time to
get
get your health in order get lucy today
so you're prepared when you get the itch
keep it on you for when you're craving
when the craving hits
the cravings only like a second or 60
seconds so you subscribe
so what you have it when you need it
lucy gum actually [__] tastes good
it comes in three flavors winter green
cinnamon and my favorite pomegranate
if you don't like the gum they also got
a cherry ice flavored lozenge
that'll make you jump up and [__]
down and salute the flag
listen with me i love the pomegranate i
love the [__] cherry ice flavored
lozenges
take a chance columbus did why do you
want to keep [__] smoking
get healthy go to lucy.com and use promo
code joey
to get 20 off all their products
including the gum and last news
that's lucy dot co use promo code joey
and here's the lawyer part warning this
product contains nicotine
no [__] derived from tobacco nicotine is
an addictive [__] chemical
but you already knew that so just go to
lucy.com and be sure to use promo code
joey
the joint is also brought to you by
stamps.com listen
you know what this life is about saving
[__] time
and making a little bit of money that's
what it's about
but time let's face it taking trips to
the post office and how you want to
spend your [__] time
that's why i recommend stamps.com you
could send letters
and packages anytime anywhere right from
your computer
stamps.com has saved businesses
thousands of
hours and tons of money my wife has been
with them i don't know 10 years
you just you can wave the package at
your house put it out in the thing and
the post office picks it up
the same with ups and get discounts up
to 40
off from the post office rates and up to
off ups shipping rates that's a lot of
[__] stamps
stamps.com is a no-brainer stop wasting
your time by going to the post office
and go to stamps.com instead
there's a no risk no risk this is what
we're gonna do use promo code joey okay
you're gonna get a special offer that
includes a four-week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitment to contracts
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone on top of the home page
and type in joey that stamps.com use
promo codejoeystamps.com
never go to the [__] post office
again it's time to get this [__]
party started it's wednesday morning
candles are lit [__] do what
you need to do uncle joey loves you
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
[Applause]
greetings from podcastville you bad
[__] it's wednesday
the 10th of the month i'm happy you're
[__] here uh
i want to thank dean delray for coming
on on monday morning
he made my week just looking at him you
know just
reminding me of i do miss a lot of
[__] people in los angeles i do mr
rogans and
all those guys but uh it was nice having
him on here
um i wasn't kidding you guys when i told
him that
he helped bring me back a little bit
with the
with the dl music and just the music all
around he was a dear friend
and i [__] love him to that so i'm
happy but we didn't get a chance to chit
chat
about what's been going on in my life
you know i'm [__] sitting there
watching tv
i'm minding my own [__] business and
all of a sudden i see this [__]
the kardashians right and i'm sitting
there and i just i was just i just
saw that it was coming on i didn't even
know like i didn't
click on to whatever the [__] it was and
i'm thinking to myself what the [__] is
the attraction with these people how the
[__] did they stay on tv
all these [__] years and people's got
sucked into it
you know i've tried watching it a couple
times i mean the show isn't bad i'm not
putting it down i'm not sitting here
saying that but who [__] sits there
religiously every week
following the [__] kardashians it's
like you know
they've created like a [__] it's like
a [__] uh soap opera living soap
opera
the husband turns [__] uh lgbtq
he switches [__] governments kanye
west is [__] crazy
the sisters must have like a [__]
plastic surgery farm
or something the chubby sister i saw a
commercial with her
that she gets migraine [__] headaches
she looks like a million [__] bucks a
chubby sister
that's a to me she's kind of cute she's
a sweetheart people always cheating on
you know
i don't know what she did to deserve
this but i mean
it's the truth i just don't [__] know
i you watch these things and you're like
what is the [__] connection
that people have to this you know but
people have connections to podcasts
people have connections to different
shows you know but that show
there's just certain things that i've
never bought into it's like the
connection
to meghan markle and that [__] pale
[__] sucker from england
i don't get it i don't [__] get it
listen i don't give a [__] of what goes
on in england
especially right now with covert and the
people dying
and the pandemic and the [__] vaccine
and the [__] 96 percent
and which you know it's like a game of
jeopardy whether we're going to live or
not
which [__] now they added an extra
[__] thing so it's either fisa
moderna or [__] johnson and johnson
johnson johnson is one shot
so you know you don't even know people
[__] calling me joy did you know how
to get a shot listen
we got a friend that's it and then
my wife got in there because she's a
smoker and she's 50
and she's got heart problems you know
i'm waiting i'm gonna wait like a month
or two
to the mass exodus before i get my
[__] vaccine
i will get it eventually i'll probably
get to johnson johnson
it's one less [__] torture session
you know listen
before i get a needle it's a week of
[__] trauma like if you call me right
now and go we need to see you march 29
in the doctor's office and you need to
do like a [__] heart test or
something and we're going to put ink in
your vein
i'm fine till the week out just sit here
with me you'll see me melt
deteriorate right in front of your
[__] eyes i think i'm just going to
do it jonathan johnson going there one
time
i'm going to bring a mattress with me
and put it next to me in case i [__]
fall
you don't know how many times i [__]
hit the deck over [__] needles last
time i fainted was a shot to the ass
when i got married before that one time
i was an acupuncture
and she didn't lay me down she just laid
me this way on the table and i was on
like a chair just like this one with
wheels and i looked up and i saw like a
needle sticking out of my [__]
shoulder
and i was like and like that's when i
that's how i tore my first meniscus on
the left side i didn't tell her because
i didn't want to feel bad
but i just looked over and i saw the
needle sticking out on my [__] thing
and i [__] just rolled off the chair
and fell that way
so that's what i'll do i just bring a
little [__] like a wrestling like a
fuji mat you know how
fuji sells mats and [__] and i'll tell a
little chinese guy listen before you
shoot me
once you see that sweater beat go down
my face [__] take the needle out
cause i'm going the opposite
[__] direction i'm even going to
position my chair so i can just roll off
onto the [__] thing
that's it i listen i hate fainting i
hate the
the feeling of going on then you're
losing [__] consciousness and [__]
but you gotta do it you know what i'm
saying i'm gonna take a piece of this
lucy call right now
this is my [__] little here's
my favorite all the flavors of
pomegranate
i gotta tell you guys something i never
told you i don't know if you know this
[__] story
i could i quit smoking i smoked twice in
my life
like an [__] and you guys listen
we'll talk about it later but i've told
you guys for years
i'm not i'm no [__] surgeon
i'm no brain genius i got my own
problems but
i have jumped out of my mike and i were
talking before the podcast
and he goes people want to hear your
opinion on that you know
when i was a kid when my mother first
died i don't know if i told you this
i did acid i started doing just
one hit you know here and there and then
i was doing it [__]
every night and then i went like on a
tear i heard these guys
there was a group of guys in my hometown
they didn't [__] drink they drank
every night throughout the
iran contra when they were holding us
hostages that was that thing that was
their way of
[__] whatever they drank for 144 days
straight
i don't know remember i don't know it's
1979 1980
i took a different route i started
taking acid
every [__] day to deal with life and
after my mother's death
for a year or maybe two from uh
maybe the beginning of 1980
to the middle of 81 i i was a
part-time masculine salesman i had the
little dots
i would go up to pennsylvania on the
weekends and buy 3 400
500 whatever i could sell you know
but part of that i was taking those and
i never i i have told you guys that you
know
part of my coming back after my mother
died what kept me together was my
friends
but it was also that i was experimenting
not with the [__] tubes and the
jacket and none of that [__] i'm not i
have a [__] fruitcake
i was [__] dropping hits every night
and my tolerance got high
i was dropping five hits a night i would
drop four hits like it was nothing
and then i would go home in the peak of
it and listen to music with earphones on
and reflect on my mom dying you know you
could see it's like an out-of-body
experience you can look within and heal
yourself
i mean it helped it didn't heal me but
it helped it kind of helped
you know i know a lot of people right
now that are micro dosing
and now the other day i read an article
that people are using as a way of
therapy and
for me i agree with it uh would i
prescribe it i'm not a [__] doctor
i'm just telling you what works for me
and it was you know like a lot of people
get mushrooms and they order empty
capsules on amazon
and they fill them up i don't know what
the weight is and then they'll just
see what they need every day and they'll
micro dose mushrooms
for psychological reasons for ptsd for
trauma
whatever even from what i was going
through which was lack of focus
you know i'm saying thank god i went
back on the shroom on the uh
alpha brain thank god i got back into
reading i mean listen
i was reading books i read the alfred
book and i read my friend's book
and i asked myself what the [__] did i
just read and i couldn't come up with a
[__] answer
so i just went back to reading books
that i had already read i'm on my second
one
in fact i wanted to read a section out
of that for you guys but we're not up to
that part yet
but i took acid as a comeback i took
acid for years
and then cocaine took over yeah and then
we moved on
but let me tell you something in the
beginning what kept me alive
was doing acid so
you know i don't know what you're going
through or whatever but i know a lot of
people like
that's why they legalize these type of
drugs i think you know a lot of these
people taking these mushrooms
i know josh was doing it i heard duncan
was doing it
i know dean delray does it from time to
time and you know what and dean's not a
junkie
those guys are not drug heads they smoke
pot whatever
but they say it helps them with their
well-being so if you're going through
something
i don't know it's just an option maybe
but i was laughing before the thing i
was talking to mike
and i was talking about lucy government
it's not bad and i use it i actually ate
all the [__] lucy gum when i got
i had to call lucy company and get more
but i started smoking at 32 years old
because when i moved to los angeles it
was 97 so i was 34.
i had never smoked a cigarette i
couldn't get in the [__] car with you
if you smoked cigarettes and finally one
day i was like [__] i
you know i was watching comics
and i noticed that even josh wolf a lot
of guys
doug stanhope a lot of guys would smoke
before they went on stage and i asked
them why do you smoke before you get on
stage and they were like well
it takes care of the nerves i go really
because i used to be [__] nervous
like we all are which are butterflies
so i picked up a [__] cigarette as
much as i hated
and it was one of the worst habits i
ever picked up never mind yet
a plan of sam and all the problems i had
cocaine i'll tell you man
cigarettes are [__] hard cigarettes
are [__] hard so i started smoking
cigarettes
i went from i would buy a pack at night
and then as i was going home i would
give them away but then i also enjoyed
the
if you do coke oh my god cigarettes are
[__] the [__]
when you do coke that's the [__] you
just burned through those [__]
cigarettes that's what i was saying the
other day
with the doug stanhope podcast when i
used to see stevo get two cartons of
cigarettes
when i was going home with an eight ball
or a gram or two
i'd get like two packs of cigarettes
maybe three buy two get one free that
type of [__]
that's how but i would i was smoking you
could ask anybody josh wolf
i could smoke two packs a [__] day i
went from smoking
casually to smoking two packs a day that
started in 1997
when i got together with my wife she
smoked and i smoked so it was not a bad
it wasn't a good [__] combination and
she was smoking marlboro lights 100s are
you [__] crazy
my wife is a [__] savage and i was
smoking camel lights
but then i got to the point where i
would smoke whatever and this is how i
quit i i
just between the reefer you know that's
why you hear that [__] wheezing in my
lungs it's not
bro my lungs are [__] tanks
they've been through hell you have no
idea what my lungs have been through
if i could pet them i would if i could
do something for my lungs
i [__] would my lungs have been
through hell they have been through hell
they deserve all the love in the world i
think about my lungs all the [__]
diamond i rub my chest
and i tell them thank you because when i
smoked i smoked when i snorted i snorted
my poor lungs have been through [__]
health they have been through
hell this last time when i did this
[__] surgery i did a
uh a chest x-ray anybody goes your lungs
look pretty good i go no emphysema
you're
no not from what i'm saying i'm like
[__] like eight years ago i had
emphysema
so me cutting down on the weeds since i
got back here and all this [__] has
helped a lot i sound a lot better i'm a
lot happier
but let me tell you how i quit smoking a
lot of people don't know this is the
technique
uncle joey decided to use because i
didn't think that i
tried the patch and made me dizzy i
tried the pill there's a pill
you could take and it [__] you up by
the mentally
you know i'd be at the comedy store
thinking i was a [__] juggler and
[__]
it just the pill made you [__] crazy
i don't know what it's called i don't
want to know
chantrum whatever the shantacs i don't
[__] know
i don't [__] know so this is how i
quit smoking
i said [__] this i got an eight ball
and i went home and i brought one
cigarette upstairs
that's it and i snorted for like three
[__] hours
dying for a cigarette because anybody
who snorts coke knows
if you don't have a cigarette you lose
your [__] mind on cocaine
same thing with drinking there's people
who like to drink
because they smoke so i was like listen
the only way i'm going to quit smoking
is i got a [__] torture myself this
is the type of guy i
am i'm i talk i break myself there's a
certain discipline you have to have as a
man
that you have to look at yourself and go
you know what i'm going to torture
myself
so i went home i got an eight ball of
coke
i took one cigarette upstairs and i
threw away my wife's cigarettes out the
window she had quit already
she had quit already she had quit
there was like an emergency pack i threw
them out the [__] window we lived on
the third floor in hollywood
i got this eight ball my wife was
sleeping and i started snorting at
eleven i had one cigarette
finally at three o'clock i broke and i
smoked that cigarette and i had another
four hours of snorting
before i get another cigarette but i
knew one thing if i could go the whole
night without a [__] cigarette like
four or five hours
that's the strength of a thousand
[__] uh that's as strong as [__]
once i realized i could go i could snort
coke without smoking
cigarettes i was good to go
and i'll never forget the first night i
that i did it after that night like i
still remember waking up
and having a call from ralphie may and
him picking me up
and i knew he wanted a small grief and i
was a little bit on the [__]
weak side and i listen if you smoke weed
you know that when you smoke weed if you
smoke cigarettes there's nothing better
than smoking a giant and following a
marlborough light
with a cup of coffee who's better than
[__] you on a monday morning
right you sit there with a [__] joint
and a cup of coffee then you blast out a
cigarette
oh it feels [__] tremendous i didn't
think you know
you like i was saying on joe diaz
project this morning
uh yesterday on patreon i was talking
about [__] uh
you you have to it all starts with your
mind like your mind has to see it
you ever actually like when i quit
cocaine i i couldn't see myself quitting
[__] cocaine
i couldn't see it until one day i could
see it and then it happened
with cigarettes like i got sick and
tired of stinking like cigarettes i got
sick
i just got sick and tired of always
having to have a [__] cigarette
around me
and i had to go outside once my wife
quit smoking i couldn't smoke in my
[__] house
and i just know that you know when you
weigh 400 [__] pounds
it's not good for when i was doing the
longest shot i was smoking
three [__] packs a day no wonder i
was 418 [__] pounds
four four packs a day and that kid lobo
salvation in the movie
he was getting free cigarettes from
marlborough so he was giving me [__]
cases
marlboro was just swinging by and going
you know just mention us in the movie or
whatever
it was [__] amazing i was taking home
all these [__] cigarettes
i was 400 [__] pounds how much time
are you gonna last
being 400 [__] pounds smoking
cigarettes so i said [__] it i'm gonna
[__] stop
one thing at a time one thing you know
everybody wants to quit everything all
at once
i'm gonna go on a diet i'm gonna quit
smoking cigarettes it's not gonna work
out somewhere along the line
it's gonna [__] fall apart on you
because you can't control that many
things
i just focused on not smoking and i
still remember ralphie may
picking me up and that's being behind el
compadre smoking a [__] number
and i still remember going [__] i need a
[__] cigarette now
and i held it off pretty soon it was day
number one
day number two day number three and
that's when i picked up
nicotine gum so nicotine gum helped me
in a way
it was a lot better than the [__]
patch i don't know why i'm telling you
this [__] story
but i figured i'd tell you the story
anyway if you're looking to quit smoking
i mean this is the way to do it i forced
myself with the [__] eight ball just
because
i knew it and you know it you know if
you do blow
or you drink there's some people that
once they quit smoking they quit
drinking
because they don't find the enjoyment no
more you know it goes hand in [__]
hand
and i understand it but anyway that's it
we'll just talk about that and leave it
at that
i had a nice [__] weekend this
weekend guys i really
you know man i'm uh
you look at me you go joey you're
looking way better you're thinking
clearer my eyes are clear
i don't look like i'm [__] uh you
know having a bag all day
i got the weight of life lifted off me
and i got to
become a regular person again you don't
know how nice that is
to just be a regular person for people
not to [__] want pictures
just for people to treat you regular
after a while i was just
you know we went through an overwhelming
period i'm not a [__] cry baby
baby i'm not you know it was just
overwhelming as a comic
um when i moved that's what the relief
is you know
but my weekends have been getting
a lot better than they were you know i'm
gonna do these four shows left
and then i'm just gonna search for
whatever joey diaz wants to do
joey diaz doesn't know what his next
step is i know that
uh the three chapters are finished
for the book so my agent asked for uh
an outline and tomorrow i'm going to
talk to
my partner in crime erica and we'll have
a
subtle outline so the wheels are moving
guys
just because i'm not doing stand-up
doesn't mean that i'm not [__]
working
you know it doesn't mean that i'm not
right it doesn't mean that
i'm not doing a podcast i even released
the spanish [__] podcast this week
it's god-awful i released it on patreon
my spanish is [__] horrendous but you
know what man
it's time to get out of my comfort zone
and try different [__] things
you know i'm getting i'm at the 70 30
mark right now with my messages
whether it's facebook twitter patreon
i'm 70 30. what does that mean 70 of the
people
are doing great thirty percent of people
are [__] struggling
and i'll tell you i'm one of those you
know i'm one of those people i'm one
i'm i'm in that percentage group but i
could tell you that i was a lot worse
when i got off the plane in august what
made it good
was in re-enjoying life re-finding
what brought me pleasure it wasn't just
comedy
it just wasn't doing a podcast my life
was just
it ran away from me sometimes you know
thank god it didn't run away from me
on drugs and [__] like that just life
was moving too fast for me
and for a lot of other comics i've
spoken to
a couple comedians the last [__] few
weeks and they've all said the same
thing to me that
bro the amount of work we were doing was
you know
in the old days comments went out
tuesday through sunday
you knew where you stood now you have
podcasts you have to be a guest on
podcast
and you have to [__] work so we were
working triple time
what we are usually comic does and this
is this isn't from my mouth
this is from other comics that were like
you know we felt we had to keep up with
tom segura
like we all felt we had to keep up with
that speed and now all of us are [__]
sit there laying there going what the
[__] is our next move
so you think you think about you know so
for me
i have to get out on the weekends i have
to do something else i have to do
something completely different
and for me i found refuge in my friends
i
i think that if you're going through
something right now
i get it i understand it but you got to
reach out to your friends
i mean therapy is therapy if you need to
see a therapist
but before you get out of control and go
i think your friends for me man
listen i wasn't having a bad week last
week i had a great week last week
i'm off the [__] pain pills that was
number one thing uh
you know i'm i'm i'm moving forward
it may not seem to it to me sometimes
i'm a little hard on myself
but i'm moving forward i'm doing things
that i never did before
we're at the two month mark from the
surgery from the knee i'm walking better
i do not trust it you know last week sam
tripley was in town
at the at the dojo comedy i love sam
i was supposed to drive out with jimmy
florentine on thursday night
jimmy florentine's son had a game so he
couldn't go thursday night
friday my wife was already had a dinner
date she was going out with her
girlfriends
and saturday is our night here we do
honeymooners white castle
you know we do all that stuff we do all
in the family i let my wife my daughter
watch all in the family
the other day he said something she it
was like a racist term and
she didn't know what it meant i said
don't you don't need to know don't need
to [__] know
but every saturday is the same thing
here we watch
bunkt and jesse on disney and then at 9
30 we throw on the uh
nine o'clock we throw on all the family
and at 9 30 we throw on the honeymoon
so saturday i was going to go saturday
night i go you know what i got to see
sam tripley
[__] i called my my i was at a
friend's house friday
and i called my buddy up my buddy called
me up george
out of the blue from fnd framing and he
calls me up and he's like i just got hit
by a guy on a bike
now george is my brother but he's got a
[__] weird sense of humor and i love
him to death
when he he told me i hit by a bike and i
landed on my ass i'm like what are you
talking you know what are you talking
about i was involved in the conversation
but i saw it was my brother calling i
don't you know i i don't want to be to
think he
he got mugs so i excuse myself for
saying like what's going on
he goes you're not going to believe it i
just got hit by a [__] guy on a bike
i know where he goes in front of my
business i landed on my ass
like what the [__] are you talking about
are you okay he goes yeah
let me call you back when i get home so
i never thought about it i didn't call
him back friday night you know i was
busy with my daughter blah blah blah
saturday i called him and i go hey man i
need a big favor from you
because guys i can't drive at night i
live in the [__] sticks
there's no streets this [__] deer is
everywhere
this the highways i could see but once i
get off the highways and get on those
numbered [__]
things i can't [__] see i called him
up i called george i go george what are
you doing you busy he goes
dawg i'm just recovering that [__]
bike hit me so hard i didn't even go to
work today i'm [__] hurt and i'm like
what are you talking about
and he goes yeah i [__] flew up in
the air when i got hit with the bike
i just flew in the [__] air and
landed like what are you talking about
and he goes yeah the guy hit me he
apologized he was a nice guy and stuff
but george went flying so george is like
i'm not going out so i was like you know
what
my wife wasn't driving me to whatever we
didn't have a baby said i can't get a
babysitter just on the drop of a [__]
dime
so i miss sam you know i felt terrible
about it i felt [__] terrible about
it
but in the other hand
it's a different life i'm living right
now right now i couldn't imagine going
somewhere
and getting covered for a reason that i
shouldn't be there
you know what i'm saying like i like and
if i would have known i would have just
gone out in a daytime and done lunch
with him
that would that would have been my
easiest [__] bet so my apologies to
sam
tripley that i didn't go support him i
love him to death
uh he's my brother i just i just don't
have it no more
you know i got obligations at the house
now i'm a different [__] man
and uh that's what's going on in my
world you know sunday
i went down to my brother came up the
one
whose wife died i went down to see him
in thomas river
from 11 30 to 2 30 and the fact that
their family took me in
and then from there i went to bobby's
house and i hung out over there in
jackson
for about three hours with my my wife
and their dog
and you know their mother-in-law lives
at them and
mercy and the mother-in-law get to get
along great so this is the same lady i
hit on 40 years ago before my mother
died
i hit on fe at the [__] park now
she's my daughter's favorite [__] she's
like a [__] standing grandmother here
in new jersey
but on the way back it was interesting
because my wife was like you know
i could see the change in you like what
are you talking about she goes when you
were talking with
mike i could see your guys 40 years you
could see the 40 years
when you were talking to bobby i could
see the 40-year friendship you know
and he goes but you might go like
[__] freaking frack
you guys are on your own [__]
language you get up at the same time you
know exact
i mean me and him were brothers you know
so i got to see him but my wife
always the reason why i'm with my wife
is because she
my wife isn't street heavy but every
once in a while she says something to me
to blow me the [__] away
you know every [__] three weeks
she'll say something to me
an observation that she makes with me
that i'm like [__]
you know i didn't even see that you know
like she
she saw that so she's like you don't
know how lucky you are
i wish i had that i have that with my
sister
but i don't have that with any friends i
go you know
it's tough to explain to people i mean i
must confuse you guys when i say my
brothers
because i tell you i have no family i
keep saying my brothers
they're my brothers i don't know how god
made it
you know how mary got pregnant remember
how mary jesus's mother was like the
immaculate conception nobody [__]
like nobody [__] like my mother didn't
[__] nobody for me to be brothers with
these people
but the way god or life or the universe
made it happen
they're my brothers mommy's my brother
[__]
uh you know mike is my brother his
brother steve
is coming over for some reefer later
he's my [__] brother you know
i mean i have 10 people jimmy lebrano
georgie
i mean these guys are like blood to me i
look at their [__] eyeballs and i
know what their next move is gonna be
you know i found out this weekend after
six months
why i moved here the reason why i moved
here was this weekend
for weekends like this one you know to
just go out and explore and
and my my daughter and wife sadly were
gone
till [__] nine o'clock at night i was
here alone
till nine o'clock i mean i did that i
did a bunch of [__] that i had to do i
went to the gym
i got together with mike we [__]
around a little bit i
you know but i she was gone until nine
o'clock
most husbands would be paid i was like
you're having
the time of your [__] life they
weren't doing this in california nobody
was inviting us over play dates
unless they wanted something from me you
know what i'm saying like people don't
write his own next thing you know
hey can you talk about this on the
podcast let me get the [__] out of here
that's why you invited my kid over here
nobody gives a [__]
nobody gives a [__] who the [__] i am or
who the [__] i'm trying to be nobody
gives a [__]
i want to talk to you guys about [__]
something i don't know if i told you
i got my first [__] guitar lesson
monday at 5
30 at zoom jimmy page look out
[__] i'm coming to light your
hands on fire you [__]
i'm going up to [__] seattle and
cutting jimi hendrix fingers
somebody already did that don't somebody
did that that's why they had to separate
jimi hendrix and bruce lisa i don't know
i don't know the whole [__] story i
took my first guitar lesson listen i did
it on zoom
you know i do all my stuff it's stays to
sound
or sound to stage i don't know what the
backwards are forward that's why i do my
ads for spotify and all that stuff
and uh i they
i found out they did lessons there like
the piano lessons my
mercy's friend nicole has piano lessons
over there and she called mercy because
the guy over here knows your dad
so my wife was like yeah joe goes down
and do his ads and stuff like that so
when i had to go read the ads last week
for rogan i [__] talked to the guy
and i go you do guitar lessons out he
goes
yeah he goes what type of guitar do you
want and i go well
my buddy i thought that you started like
a classical guitar
but he gave me the [__] best guitar
in the world some [__] stratocaster
deluxe or something
so i go i don't know and he goes yeah
[__] people learn on the [__]
electric guitar all the time he goes i
got the perfect guy goes give me your
influences and i told him you know i
love david gilmour
i love paige i love this guy i mean i
love so many [__] guitarists you know
i love tom morello
you know it's so hard to land the style
you know the
today i opened up yesterday i opened up
a rock lobster on patreon
i love that guitar at the end of rock
laps that little heroin addict
could [__] that guitar up like it was
nobody business
rest his soul i think he died after the
second hour but listen to the beginning
of your own private idaho
like if you listen to the chords on the
beginning of the own private idaho
jesus christ that [__] guy didn't
[__] around
this live footage right now on youtube
of rock lobster like
them in a bar from 79 watch that [__]
watch that [__] guitar player
he shreds another guy i like that a lot
of people don't
ever talk about is the little [__]
[__] from [__] the cars oh
[__] he's some strong island some little
guitar player
the guy does the leads on candio and all
that [__] that guy don't [__] around i
forget what his name is
one of you guys will tweet it to me i
love that [__] i [__] you know my my
my influences rage from clapton the
racist
a couple weeks ago you people all mad at
clapton because in 73
he said some racist [__] he was on
heroin
what the he was in love with [__]
george harrison's wife give him a break
you know what i'm saying can you imagine
being loved into somebody else's wife
you hate everybody arabs
spanish people black people you don't
give a [__] yeah you're in love with
somebody else's wife
you know i love clapton i love paige
i love [__] gilmore
i love wyoming you know angus forget
about it you know
the other day i was trying i was
listening to let there be rock i was
trying to learn the chords to overdose
by myself oh my god
i almost overdosed on pain it was so
[__] horrible
i was cause mike and everybody's like oh
you can learn teach yourself how to play
the guitar
just put like an arm on whatever i'm on
youtube so i said [__] all this [__]
i'm just gonna get a [__] zoom lesson
and i learned a couple things i learned
like bing bang
bang so it's just on the bottom like the
g
chord and i play and i play that so last
night i did my [__] exercises my wife
went to bed
and i came back here and did my little
thing today mike's gonna tell me how to
hook up the [__] amp
for my lesson tomorrow because he wants
me to have my [__] amp
and i'm off from running for you
[__] who sent me emails on
facebook that said i sucked
god bless you god bless you god bless
you
you you're cooking with all [__]
measures here i just took my first
guitar lesson
i expect to suck for the next three
[__] years how's that one for you
so if you thought i was trying to be
jimmy page
it was a joke do you guys know the
difference between a joke
and a [__] you know i'm no guitar
player i'm barely a [__] comedian i'm
barely walking and chewing gum at the
[__] same time
and you people put me down some guy that
just woke up on a bad [__] day
saw a video of me playing the guitar and
[__] facebook me that i'm terrible i
don't know what i'm doing no [__]
sherlock
you just [__] noticed that you're
that you're a [__] genius for
noticing that
people that ride shuttles it's amazing
it's amazing it's amazing it's amazing
that
listen and i get it you're waiting for
unemployment
your job furloughed you somebody close
to your past from covid
you know these are frustrating times
but [__] lashing out at people
that's just not it's not cool right now
we have enough [__] problems going on
yeah oh well megan markley said
that the kids are pale i don't give a
[__] people are dying to [__] covet
was that something about the kids being
pale she doesn't want the color of the
piano
the british people somebody in the
family said something to them about
oh are you worried about how the shade
or the color of your
child those ugly [__]
that listen for [__] a prince family
or king or whatever the [__] they are
they're the ugliest white people i've
seen in a long time i haven't seen ugly
people like that since i went to
mountain new jersey
they [__] pale they got problems the
one prime minute they're the ugliest the
old lady i don't know what the [__]
listen you know what i stay out of that
[__] i don't it's got nothing to do with
uncle joey i got enough
chips walking around trying to be a
[__] dad now i gotta worry about
megan [__] marklin what she's [__]
doing
who gives a [__] at the end of the week
i just give a [__] about this circle
right here i give a [__] about mike
i give a [__] about you people i give a
[__] about your lives if you're healthy
if you're hungry if you're eating
if you're [__] down if you're happy
whatever that's what i give a [__] about
the people in my [__] immediate
circle and how i could help them
people in england what am i gonna do
i can't even send a shirt to great
britain did you know that really
yeah there's a [__] new tax you gotta
go around so i can't send merch to
[__] great britain now i don't know
what's going on over there
but me you know me i mind my business
and i keep pushing
as far as the spanish podcast this is my
plans
i'm gonna lay it down on patreon for a
few weeks
i'm gonna talk about music and [__] like
that introduce a little music
just for a few weeks and then i'm going
mainstream with the spanish podcast i'm
gonna have zooming guests
that speak spanish you know whatever
controversial guest whatever
you know it's funny i was sitting for
three weeks trying to ponder
how i was gonna do this podcast in
spanish
and again i went back to joey diaz's
[__] side you know
we all have the our [__] side of us and
no disrespect to nobody
we all have our little [__] side that
procrastinates everything
you know you're not special we all have
it including me
you know it's not procrastination it's
that i don't want to fail
nobody wants to fail but you know what
if you don't fail
you're not going to [__] learn
anything so for three weeks i was
[__] sitting there
you know how am i going to do this latin
podcast blah blah blah
spanish podcast i really want to do it
my spanish isn't up to par
i understand that but i don't give a
[__]
so yesterday morning monday morning i
woke up
i had to go to pt and i got up early you
know i kissed a baby to go to school but
she goes out to the front i watch till
the bus comes i came back in and i go
you know what today's the [__] day
no more procrastination no more thinking
no that's the problem is we overthink
everything and i'm included
i raise my hand i'm guilty of that [__]
too you try to overthink especially now
when you have nothing else to go through
your mind you overthink everything to
the last detail
to the point of you get scared it's
natural
it's it's whatever me i got up
i was [__] uh monday i got up in the
morning
i we did the podcast whatever mercy
and i've been reading again i told you
that for me to get mentally strong and
for me to help write
i knew i had to read so jimmy florentine
gave me the biography i read that first
erica gave me her book i read that first
my comprehension levels were horrible
you know when poor mike mike is a saint
and he's trying to teach me the guitar
and i can't comprehend it
because he's my friend i can't
comprehend what he's saying to me i got
to have
i'm very anal when it comes to that like
i could you know like my cousin just
called before
i liked jiu jitsu i wanted to learn
jujitsu
you know what you go down there you want
to learn a little actually you got a
private
whatever but i'm the type of guy i want
to learn from a professional
like when i lift weights you know i have
somebody there with me i do semi-private
uh training you know why because i want
somebody to watch me i'm not a weight
lifter i don't know what the [__] i'm
doing
when i was a kid yeah i did five six or
six
behind the neck bent over rows one arm
crack all that [__]
and what happened now my shoulders are
all [__] up i can't raise my shoulders
up i've been working on i've been doing
functional training
but if i'm not an expert in something
you know a lot of people
do their own thing me i know i'm a
[__] idiot
okay before we even get this
conversation started i know me and i
know what i could do
i know what i can't do and there's
nothing wrong with having shortcomings
we all have [__] shortcomings but one
shortcoming i don't have that pisses me
off
is that i procrastinate but
i do have [__] balls like that's the
only thing that's that pisses me off
sometimes
that i catch myself procrastinating
something and it could be anything
wednesdays when i wake up and i gotta go
do comedy i procrastinate
it's just something natural and then i
think about my balls
and i go what the [__] you know i just
gotta read this to you just a
an excerpt from a book
i thought it was very interesting to me
to read this i thought this was great
this is from the book the corporation
i picked this up just because i had read
it before
it's a great book but i read
this and it really really made me think
about
me and this is why i started the podcast
this is
you know this goes back to the move this
goes back to [__] everything
one thing that could be said and often
was about jose miguel battle
was that he had big balls cojones in
latin culture
it is important it as in
most patriarchal societies being noted
for having big balls
was a metaphor for courage and the
highest form of praise
machismo is the logical manifestation of
the philosophy
the belief that all life originates with
the male organ
and the precious seed that is after all
conjured from within the testicles big
balls
connote power because a person with big
is a person without fear
that's an excerpt from the corporation
and i kept it
i even [__] kept the card in there i
kept reading
because i wanted to read that to you the
meatballs is everything
when you see me get up in the morning
and i write that thing like he keeps
talking about
balls and [__] and and grab your
balls it's because
in my society balls are [__]
everything from a cuban standpoint
if you don't have [__] balls
it's not gonna work out for you you
understand me it starts with your
[__] balls
it connects with your [__] brains and
then you make your [__] move and
that's it and that's [__] that that's
not [__] easy
but it all starts with balls and you
gotta grow a pair from time to time and
trust me
it took me a long [__] time to have
balls because people
i could continue reading that it also
said that having balls
means sometimes that you're not that
intelligent
and that's where i come in i'm not that
intelligent i never sat across from you
and told you i'm intelligent
i have told you one thing i got the
[__] balls to back up whatever the
[__] i tell you
and i back it up 150 whether it's my
comedy
whatever when i beat myself up it's
because i sucked
it's not because you know i don't like
to lie to myself i
i'm straight up with myself so when i
read that i got so [__] pissed off
i'm like that's absolutely right
my culture is about [__] balls
you got to grab your [__] bingo and
go out there and sling [__] dick and
i'll keep saying i when i read that
i stopped in my [__] tracks because
it's true i've eliminated the machismo
[__] from my life when i was a kid when
i was like 18
19 i had that cuban machismo and i
realized it wasn't going nowhere
that jealousy all those are [__]
weaknesses
to me they were you know uh you know you
get jealous with girls you get
all that [__] i had to remove from my
life because i knew it wouldn't work
and that takes [__] balls to do that
[__] it just
won't [__] work man and that's why
listen everybody knows and that's what
everybody will [__] tell you i'm not
that [__] smart
i'm not that [__] good looking i'm
not the [__] keenest guy in the world
but when it comes to balls i'm right
there with the [__] best of them i
don't give a
[__] yeah i don't like needles but some
people don't like but i know guys i have
bigger balls than me
and say to me i don't know how you do
what you do but i have a friend that is
[__] deadly deadly as a human being
deadly do you understand what i'm trying
to say to you when i talk to this guy
he reminds me once a month about how he
has
he'd rather die than go up on stage
it's a scary thing i've offered him like
five grand to do a guest set just one
minute go up there and just do a [__]
joke like i told him when i did like
theaters and [__]
i go come over to new york and you have
to conquer that fear and he's like
[__] you that's one fear i don't want to
conquer
this guy has killed before this guy has
done 20 years in [__] jail
you know he just got out maybe eight
years ago and we became friends again
you know i i've known him
from grammar school listen his biggest
[__] fear this guy has stabbed people
he's put guns in people's mouths and
[__] he doesn't give a frenchman's [__]
he's told me things have made me [__]
cringe
but his biggest fear he goes i don't
know how you do it
he goes you doing that made me love you
even more he goes when i watch you and
those [__] comedy central things
i'm sweating for you he see he's like
i'm up there sweating for you because
i don't know how the [__] he do it he'll
stab petting 10 guys
he'll shoot 10 guys but he won't go he
says he's even embarrassed
to talk in a group at a table i i felt
that before but
people get embarrassed people just don't
like it some people just don't like it
we all don't what makes the world go
around is that we all don't like the
same thing can you imagine if all of us
were the [__] same
i think a guy left patreon a couple
weeks ago and i know i'm gonna say this
and you guys are not gonna be happy with
it
he asked me what my favorite bill murray
is that his name
movie was i told him right now i go i'm
not a big bill murray guy
he was like how can you be a comedian
not be a big bill murray guy go
dog everything's not for everything i'm
a big harold ramus guy
i loved [__] uh bill murray and
stripes you know
i didn't like ghostbusters i walked out
of ghostbusters with the dude
who stabbed 20 guys that did 20 years i
went to see ghostbusters i used to go to
movies with him
we used to go to movies all the time
charles bronson movies we were fans you
know he's not from north bergen
he's from he lived in fort lee but this
guy just got out of [__] doing time
we used to go to movies all the time and
we had we used to go to movies and
concerts together
and we both had the exact taste to the
[__]
me and him would go to a movie and also
we just look at us ourselves
and go let's get the [__] out of here we
walked out of twisted sister
we walked out of ghostbusters we walked
out of 20 [__] things together
and we would just go home i remember one
time i gave her the ass and he went home
i go what he goes i'll never do that
again yeah because you went home
who the [__] goes home on a hit of
[__] acid to look at your mother and
father that's [__] humiliating
you should have stayed out with me and
walked around and gone to the park and
thrown bottles at people anything
but you don't [__] go home and i hit
acid anyway
that's the way life works is
yeah you're gonna go home and [__]
look at the walls and [__] the first
time you do ass
you need to be around three or four
people and you know talk
and [__] walk or whatever the [__]
you're doing listen to music but you
just can't [__] go home
and sit and stare at your [__] your
parents you [__] lose your mind
i have a hard time just getting high
with my wife in the [__] house
i go outside to get high come back in
they look at you like you're [__]
johnny creepo
and that's just [__] weak can you
imagine an acid favorite is looking at
you you're all [__]
your eyes are glowy i don't know one
time we did [__] ketamine
in the [__] office i'm not going to
tell you that's the only time
we [__] for the guy who had the
secret tape of us doing blow
from 2006 i've got undercover footage
of joey dears going blow no we never did
blow
and that's lee we never did [__] blow
we had blow in the office but we gave it
away to people who
had a guy that dropped off a package
from time to time
and would say hey take this i don't do
it no more and there was a picture of
lee i would hide it behind lee's picture
so if the cops came they thought it was
lease
there was a picture of me and a picture
of lee behind the door
so it had a ledge to it like it was like
an artist draw it so i would
take the [__] picture and put the
package there and then when somebody
would come in that did coke i'd ask them
you want some bloat
no really yeah boom and they [__]
take it but
one time a guest came and they brought
some [__] ketamine i was like
what the [__] and i did like two or
three lines
lee did like two or three lines and then
he left it behind
like he took a baggie with him but he
left like a half a gram
on the [__] table and you know me
doug
all habits die hard i'm like lee what
are we going to do with this we just
can't put in a package
you know you just can't put it away
because it's going to be here haunting
us let's just [__] finish it
now the first two or three lines weren't
that [__] bad i gotta be honest with
you they weren't bad at all
it was when we split that little pile up
me and lee
it was like nine o'clock at night we
split that little [__] pile
and i thought nothing was gonna happen
we had an edible on us we had a bunch of
[__] in this
and dog after i did that line i got up
to pee and i was like
oh [__] i am [__] up so i went in i
peed i washed my hands i got my [__]
back
i gotta get the [__] out of it he's like
where you going i gotta get the [__] out
of here
i went downstairs i got my [__] car
and i have to light
all out of drivers to a light make a
left go down
past one light and i was home so i'm
like
you would never [__] see cops and i
would you know
and i didn't have any alcohol on my
breath so i was fine you know unless he
looked at my eyes and they were pinned
get in the [__] car on this [__]
ketamine and i make that left turn at
the first light
it's colfax and it go i'm on chandler
and i'm making a left onto colfax
and as i'm making a left around it felt
like i was in a [__]
at a amusement park
i like i made the [__] left i'm like
oh my god
uncle joey's [__] up on this ketamine
then at the next light was where yum yum
donuts was i'm
sitting at magnolia and i'm looking at
yum yum donuts and [__]
and i'm like what the [__] the sign was
starting to wave
i'm like joey you're [__] up i get to
my block i make the [__] left
i pull up in the driveway and when i
take my left foot to land on the floor
i open up the side door the passenger
the driver's side door
they get out of the car and when i put
my foot on the [__] door
on the floor i could feel it creeping
unless this drug was in full effect
i'm like oh my god i'm [__] up
i walked in that all the nights usually
when i get home at night my wife's out
very seldom with that [__] living
room tv beyond
it was like 10 30 on a sunday night i'm
figuring my wife is
out she's passed out we got that one
the scary thing was we got to the office
like got four
the podcast was like at four and we got
so [__] high
we stayed there till like [__] 9 30
10 o'clock
the podcast finished like at seven we
were just so [__] high talking back
and forth all three of us and the guests
left
and then we had that pile and we did it
when i [__] walked in the house i
opened up that door and i seen the tv
was on
i [__] [__] my pants i'm like god
damn it now i gotta face my wife
and that's somebody have a hard time
facing when i'm [__] up
so i i honey i'm home i gotta
you know she said yeah i could i could
hear you
i went into my [__] office and i'm
sitting in the office
i got like a hooded sweatshirt like a
hoodie a t-shirt on
whatever and i'm like boy it's getting
[__] hot in here and i'm like
oh it's getting [__] hot here i take
the [__] hoodie off
and do you believe it's still [__]
hot in here i'm like woof
that's too [__] hot in here and then
i took my t-shirt off i'm down to just
titties now
sitting by myself in front of the
computer screen something i don't like
doing i don't sit in front of the
computer standing my top off
because i got that camera on me so
somebody could be watching me with my
[__] shirt off
my tits out i don't need that in my life
so i'm like i'm going to get off this i
i
shut the computer down and i just sat at
my desk getting higher and higher
the edibles and the ketamine were
[__] i think ketamine is like an
animal tranquilizer
the guy who gave it to us told us that
they'd they tried it on experiments that
too that's another drug that they're
working on ptsd
and different [__] forms of brain
[__] things they're using ketamine
also
so he said it's good they give it to
[__] people i don't know what the
[__] he meant
i know for a fact i was [__] [__]
at the end of the night i was sitting
there
[__] up and i'm like i gotta tell you
something i better go out there and sit
with my wife before she comes in here
and sees what's going on so i put my
t-shirt on
and i went out to the living room and i
sat with her she was watching true
detective
that i don't know i think that's what
it's called on hbo this had to be two
three years ago
she's watching true detective and i'm
sitting there next to her
i'm like hi and i just sit there and
she's not even looking at me
but i'm watching this tv and i'm getting
[__] up
and it was i think it was the guy from
blade the guy that played the head
vampire in blade it was his season
and the african-american guy that was in
the green book
and i was looking at the
african-american guy that was the green
book
and his head kept getting square like
for some reason i'm watching the tv
and this brother's head is going from
being a regular [__] head
to like a box like it got square and i'm
looking at this and i'm looking at my
wife
and i'm looking at this and i'm looking
at my wife i'm like oh my god this
this brother's head is getting square or
i'm seeing a [__] square
oh my god and finally i started freaking
out my wife is looking at me and i'm
sweating profusely
i'm trying to cover my face with him
trying to just like wipe it with the
[__] thing
i'm sweating there and finally his head
got so [__] square i couldn't take it
no more and i go honey you gotta [__]
change this
and she looked at me she goes fine
change it what's what's the big deal
you gotta [__] change it that's it
and she goes okay fine and she got him
went to the other room to watch it
i'm just sitting there like [__] i
switched the channel to some [__]
channel
just to sit there i was so [__] up i
didn't tell her that night that i did it
i told her like the next day i did some
ketamine i was [__] she's like how
old are you
what the [__] is wrong with you i was so
[__] up
from that ketamine she went in i think i
stayed there for another hour i came
down
and that was the end of the night it
wasn't that bad of a drug it didn't
[__] kill me or nothing
i never did it again i pay that much i
don't even want to be that [__] up
i don't want to be that [__] up ever
again ever since i moved here i made the
move
i can't handle a lot of [__] no more i
can't handle what i was doing
in l.a like edibles you don't see me eat
no smoking things in the daytime
the last time we were [__] around
here one day do you remember i sprayed a
couple sprays in my mouth
jesus two hours later i wasn't [__]
planning mars so
my edible consumption is done that [__]
is all done with
i use edibles now to go to [__] sleep
i pop
three of those [__] edibles and a cup
of tea at night that kick them ot
you don't even see me till the next day
sometimes i fall asleep on the [__]
couch here lately i've been making it
upstairs because
i don't want to force to fall asleep on
the couch and having my wife come down
and get me
that's a [__] nightmare but anyway
it's been a great [__] week man
and i'm happy you guys are still
supporting me i'm happy you're still
part of the [__] joint
you know i'm i'm having my struggles but
i'm pushing [__] through guys
this is very hard for me to do but hey
we're trying our [__] best
so what i'm gonna mix it up a little bit
i'm gonna try to do a zoom guy
on mondays and then we'll have a little
chat on [__] wednesdays
until we get the new office and then
we'll [__] go full boat out but
man without a plan it's not a man at
least i got a [__] plan
and then the latin podcast the spanish
podcast is also going to go mainstream
once i figure it out and i get my
spanish down and whatnot so we'll have
two podcasts going
one exclusively in spanish one
exclusively in english
the joint in english and a lot of the
scottish guy in spanish
for you people who don't know what la
descadaga means in spanish
it means a [__] hear beating what i
give you people every monday and
wednesday and every thursday and friday
on [__] patreon there's a [__]
here beating the life
some of you just enjoy it some of you is
like [__] you cocksuck i'm making a pass
but hey
if you're here i love you and if you're
not here i still love you too i don't
give a [__] people gotta come and go
i'm not the only game in town i know
that going in so i'm appreciating you
[__] still watching the podcast
still supporting me and still being on
patreon you know i got a kind note
the other day that's kind i gotta get
must have been the scallops i had for
lunch at the brown rice i'm trying to be
a little healthy you know what i'm
saying
the other dog this fart is tremendous i
just got away from it
it's [__] tremendous if you've
noticed i haven't been farting on the
podcast as much
you know somebody sent me an email the
other day and it's very nice email
you know i don't like to base the
podcast around emails
when i do get an email i'm like a
[__] priest or a lawyer
it's my business with i will never do
you send me an email and a lot of people
on patreon
say this to me like hey man i've never
said this to nobody
so when i address an email sometimes
it's because i might see it on facebook
or patreon or twitter
or something like that but somebody sent
me a very kind
note and they said that they had
listened to the joint a couple times
and they were a little disappointed they
said i'm not gonna lie to you
i lo first of all with me i love honesty
i [__] love honesty if you're
listen there's a way to say things and
there's a way not to say things
you can't go go up to somebody and say
hey you suck
but you go up to somebody and say i
disagree with what you're doing if you
say it correctly in the right way
unless you're dealing with a [__]
jack off
they're not going to come at you it's
like when i tell the story about matt
when we were talking about with doug
stano i told the story about matt
uh whatever his name is that came and
gave me a talking to
you know i took it wrong and at that
time i was a jerk off
and yes i walked to the train the bus
station
and then i walked back to [__] smack
him but
days later i came to my wits about me
and i was like the guy was right
you know what's right that's right you
know i love honesty
a couple weeks ago some girl on patreon
said listen
i didn't up the tia i upped the tia with
a motive
i wanted to talk to you about stand up
calm and i go just come down uncle
vinnie's into a [__] spot
i simplified her [__] life for her
she goes i never really whatever
you know don't ask me for a spot i'm not
going to give it to you i'm just letting
you know how i respond to different
[__] people
if you send me an email with honesty i
[__] my dick gets hard i
don't i don't give a [__] if you put me
down and go joe you're too [__] fat
and i've had people reach out to me and
say some kind things to me hey man
you're slipping over here you're doing
too many jobs we had people that reached
out to me on the podcast and and i
accepted them and i didn't
yell at them or go back at them it's
when you come at me
like a [__] jerk-off that sure you
know sometimes
i go that person is having a bad day i
won't even re-answer them
but sometimes i'll lash out we all do
you know
you're doing something nice with your
kid you sit down you open up a message
and it's somebody [__] attacking you
for no [__] reason
and saying a bunch of [__] to you that
[__] doesn't piss me off it just makes
me feel sorry for you
you know like what the [__] are you
thinking but this guy wrote me a kind
email and he was like listen
i've listened to you for 10 years i love
everything that you do
this podcast i listen to the first four
episodes
and it was kind of disappointing
whatever to me whatever
but he goes i went
and i took a breather i listened to a
few churches
and i thought about it after watching
the churches what you were doing
you were trying to reinvent yourself and
i didn't see it
that's why you don't smoke on the
podcast that's why you never wear the
white t-shirts on a podcast no more
that's why you don't fall on the podcast
no more you're coming back as an older
wiser
you know i learned i know the podcast
game i'm a 10-year [__] veteran of it
uh this isn't the best podcast out there
there's 20 000 better podcasts in it
but you're not going to get somebody
who's as honest and as the heart that i
have
and telling you a story or talking to
you about a situation or anything like
that that's where
my strength lies some people don't like
that some people
rather hear you know none
uh or whatever just a conversation
there's a lot of podcasts i do and i
don't
i don't get the point of them why i do
them i really don't because
it's just too too much i want to get
something from you know
i want to bang for my buck you know when
i listen to a podcast
i want to laugh i want to learn
something you know with the church
we were doing and that's what he said he
goes you guys are doing drugs
you guys are doing and he goes i kind of
miss that but
now i see what you're trying to do and
he goes i'm happy that you didn't give
up and i'm happy that you push
forward and i'm happy that you're doing
it you know and that's what it's all
about it's balls
keep sticking to your [__] plan and
keep pushing this
is weighing everybody down this has
changed the game
for everybody every time on cbs blue
blood design six days a [__] week
right [__] everything is on eight
days a week have you noticed that
i mean this has affected everybody
what i'm trying to do here is just
lighten your load for an hour and let
you know
that you're not going through this alone
i'm going through this
you could see it in my [__] face i
mean yeah i'm happy
that i'm going through this but
everybody's going through something
you're not going through this alone
you don't need to turn yourself into the
loony bin you don't need to
the best therapy is your friends your
friends are right in front of you
reach out to your friends i've been
reaching out and i felt a lot better
i've reached out to
all the comics that left la from theo to
[__] josh wolfe
to bert i mean you know i didn't know
the sigur was moving to texas
in a few weeks reach out to your friends
they're the best therapy
they love you they know you don't not
reach out to them because of what you're
going through
you don't need extensive therapy or
whatever if you
if the love of your friends can't help
you out then you turn to therapy
but your friends are there for you they
should be there for you that's what
they're there for
tell them what you're going through you
know i thought i was honest with rich
voss and jimmy florentine and everybody
i told them man i'm struggling with this
i don't want to go do comedy and big
venues and [__] like that yet they get
it
we go meat we all wear masks we go to
lunch whatever
you know we're pushing through this push
through this don't give up
don't let the situation take you down
we'll be back next monday for another
fun-filled week
of podcasts and patreon and facebooking
and
talking about my stinky balls until then
i love you [__]
enjoy the ads and have a great week
remember
uncle joey loves you and now to a word
from our sponsors
all right that was a nice little chit
chat on a wednesday morning
what the [__] you know what i'm saying
it's your uncle joey talking to you from
the heart
as always before i leave i'm going to
talk to you about a few things for
number one stamps
motherfucking.com you know how much time
you can save
by [__] going with stamps.com let's
face it taking trips to the post office
and how you want to spend your time
that's why i recommend
stamps.com my wife has been with them
for 10 years she loves them you can send
letters
ship packages anytime anywhere right
from your computer
and pay less get discounted rates from
usps
ups and more stamp.com has saved
thousands of hours and tons of money for
businesses
whether big or small i don't give a [__]
if you send out three hats a month
stamps.com is going to help you and you
can save time
if you've got a business stamps.com is a
must-have
print us postage for any letter any
package any class of mail
send anywhere in the world that's a
schedule pick up and make
the mailman will come to you who's
better than you nobody or
drop it off yourself it's that simple
but get discounts up to 40
off post office rates and 62 percent ups
shipping rates
that's a lot of stamps stamps.com is a
no-brainer
no wonder a million small businesses
already use stamps.com
so i'm inviting you guys today to stop
wasting your [__] time by going to
the post office
and standing there and just go to
stamps.com
there's a no risk trial okay use promo
code joey i'm gonna throw you a special
offer that includes
four-week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale
who's better than you nobody no
long-term commitments or contracts
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone on the top of the home page
and type in joey that stamps.com
use promo code joey stamps.com
never go to the post office again and
from the heart of jersey
we're brought to you by [__]
draftkings the best
listen right now download the draftking
sportsbook
why [__] around why play games you got
you know how much fun i've been having
on draftkings do you have any [__]
idea no you don't
it's [__] fun they got a nice parlay
for you tonight i was telling you at the
beginning of the game
you got san antonio versus dallas you
could bet the game the total there's
odds boosts there's teasers
and listen you're not gonna [__]
you're not gonna go over your head
because it's you're already [__]
right there it's not like calling the
bookie and telling them to put a bet in
that you gotta pay the rent two thousand
and you don't have it no
you can't bet if you can't play you keep
it small and you [__] bet and you
make a little money from time to time
i mean [__] the biggest college
basketball tournament of the year
is getting ready to [__] heat up and
the clock is ticking as the seas get
ready to tip
off get off the [__] bench and get
into tournament action
they're gonna listen they got a deal for
you this weekend you bet four thousand
under the dog
if they win you're up to 256 dollars
that's [__] insanity
if anybody knows about betting on an
underdog it's your uncle joey
look at me now i was an underdog there's
no better way to put your college
basketball knowledge to the test
than by putting your money where your
[__] mouth is with draftkings
sports book college ball ain't for you
okay
draftking sportsbook has great odds and
promotions on the nba
nba [__] playoffs golf hockey and so
much more
they got a [__] tremendous casino
draftkings is america's top rated
sportsbook app
it's safe secure reliable and you
withdraw your money when you want it's
your [__] money knucklehead
who's better than you nobody's gonna
take your [__] money right now
download the top-rated draftking
sportsbook app today
use promo code joy when you sign up and
you can turn
4 hours into 256 dollars and it's bad it
starts tonight
with san antonio at the dallas [__]
mavericks it's like tonight
tonight you got to play right there that
line is soft look at the [__] totals
so by the time the weekend comes and the
brackets come you'll be ready to rock
to turn 4 into 256 dollars
for a limited time only at draftkings
sportsbook and here's the part the
lawyers make me say
you got to be 21 older take your [__]
roller skates and roll down a hill
new jersey indiana pa only new customers
only
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details you got a
gambling problem
call 1-800 gambler or in indiana 1-809
with it
but if you're [__] all [__] down
to [__] play
download the draft draftking sportsbook
app now
and tell him uncle joey sent you stop
[__] around
the joint is also brought to you by lucy
nicotine gum
listen it's hard to quit smoking you
know i did it it's [__] hard i did it
differently though i'll tell you how i
did it later
when you're craving the smoke you just
need a little something to satisfy the
habit
that's why i love [__] lucy things
may be rough but you don't need to smoke
anymore
get lucy today so you're prepared when
you get the itch
keep it on you when you're craving hits
and subscribe so when you
need it you have it lucy gum actually
tastes [__] good
it comes in three flavors winter green
cinnamon pomegranate
my favorite is the pomegranate and if
you don't like gum they also got the
cherry ice flavored larsens
that will make you jump up and down and
salute the flag 25 [__] times
try the pomegranate try the wintergreen
tie the cinnamon but it's better than
you [__] ruining your health with
cigarettes
uncle joey's joints listeners do me a
favor go to lucy.com
use promo code joey to get 20 percent
off all products
including gum or lozenges that's lucy
dot co
use promo code joey at checkout and
here's the lawyer part
this product contains nicotine derived
from tobacco
nicotine is an addictive [__]
chemical
but you already know that so just go to
lucy.gov
and be sure you use that promo code joey
i love you [__] stay black
i hope you enjoyed the podcast this week
i'm on patreon three
five and ten dollars album of the week
reefer re-for
the week [__] spanish podcast
whatever i'm doing it i'm hustling we're
awesome we gotta keep moving forward
no matter how you feel i love you
[__] have a great week
and thank you for listening to uncle
joey's joint
now go [__] make some of yourself and
be a savage [__] i love you
[Music]
so
you